they the multis presidency presented a
compromise proposal to ensure stronger
protection to consumers when they want
to shop up line i'm very pleased that
council agreed on a general approach to
strengthen consumer protection
cooperation in the internal market the
presidency also presented a cop report
on the ongoing discussions to reform the
type approval and market surveillance
for motor vehicles our intention is to
present the text of a general approach
to the competitiveness council the
former competitive council in in May
today member states agree there should
be a more effective enforcement and
enforcement adapted to the digital era
this arrangement brings some new tools
as we had proposed in particular
consumer authorities will have more
enforcement powers online we are also
improving the eu-wide market
surveillance system so in the text
emerging threats more rapidly through
good implementation of the new
directives of on public documentary can
really support innovation which can
support a sammies and we can also
support social and environmental
policies the second point during lunch
we discussed European industrial
competitiveness what we have achieved
discussing smart industry discussing
clean industry and as well as how people
could seize opportunities offered by the
new industrial revolution and last but
not least only just just to just mention
only European intercut and all of the
member states that are in the process of
ratification also confirmed today that
they are at the very last stage last
moment together with Germany and UK so
hopefully we'll have European interest
patent adopted this year